all right here we go we're gonna do some
trading which is new in the game except
this is the dark zone version of that I
guess so raid within your group would
think so let's take a look at how that
works I've never done it so share item
let's look at all there you go I'm
sharing the item sure is it on the
ground down oh yeah yeah uh with that
pistol by the way I lost it ah i see the
one I'll grey convenient JK computer
talk well go down there you oh you got
three things yeah you can drop that so
you hold the right sure you want this
purple responder holster ah that's fine
oh you know what you should keep that
dude that's a 182 this pistol yeah it's
higher than my pistol i think i'll give
it to you did all right fine I'll take
it that's yours a look at the oh yeah
i'm getting the option we're like of the
stuff i picked up yeah 43 minutes to
share it right Oh a little blue goes no
but like mites for instance these
performance mods once I apply them I
can't share them oh gotcha I shouldn't
have blue those items up actually I
should ask if they're better for you but
I don't think they would have been
because they weren't that great and I
was already yeah so that's kind of cool
so like the trading to build upon our
trading from earlier now that we kind of
extracted it from the dark zone like I
could give you wait where is it what can
I give you oh yeah so this is the pistol
you gave me I could give that back to
you right mask that's weird I thought I
had some armor that I picked up that
yeah is weird right these aren't sure
aren't sure who's weird in the minds of
thing but it was shareable oh wait you
my last one oh yeah this one so oh so it
has the icon so the best way to tell
that it's trading a birthday lil
exchanged item here on the right actual
item so this one I could share I don't
know if you need a backpack no like a oh
electronics backpack with crit hit
damage ammo actually yeah
if you need it here you go so by doing
that drop that strike backpack we got
from the dark zone that I extracted and
Rob can now pick that up if you would
wants it guess he doesn't want upstairs
goes